hallo leute wir sind diese woche in
frankreich
wir haben einen trip aufs land gemacht
sind jetzt hier auf einem wunderschönen
hof und bäume gucken was macht man hier
die ganzen tag eigentlich so los geht's
ich bin hier mit mit und li und ich
möchte jetzt unbedingt mal den
rasenmäher ausprobieren
ach so wir müssen erst tanken
wir haben kein benzin für den rasenmäher
na gut
[Musik]
erzielt so losgeht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist ein so genannter aufsitzmäher
oder auch rasentraktor wir werden jetzt
erst mal das benzin auffüllen und dann
kann ich auch gleich mal fahren darauf
freue ich mich schon
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein
[Musik]
der rasen ist gemäht
ich glaube ich habe mich jetzt an das
land leben gewöhnt und kann jetzt solch
große maschinen fahren
das
[Musik]
mitch hat in der scheune ein paar
werkzeuge besucht die wir euch jetzt
vorstellen möchten
mit hat eine gießkanne um die blumen zu
gießen
dann hat er einen besen mitgebracht eine
heckenschere dann hat mit noch einen
spaten mitgebracht
außerdem hat mitch noch eine harke zum
laub harken mitgebracht dann hat mitch
noch zwei werkzeuge mitgebracht die man
für holz nutzen kann
eine axt und eine säge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
li und mitfahren jetzt in den wald wo
noch etwas holz liegt dass wir dann zu
feuer holz verarbeiten werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mitch und lee sind mit dem holz zurück
jetzt nutzen wir diesen holzspalter um
die einzelnen stücke in jeweils zwei
teile zu spalten
mal schauen wie das geht
diese farm ist gleichzeitig auch ein
weingut jetzt wo der tag so langsam zu
ende geht dachte ich mir
machen wir doch mal einen wein und
trinken den wie lange ja okay das dauert
offensichtlich viel zu lange also
brauchen wir eine andere lösung
so jetzt haben wir unseren beiden viel
schneller und einfacher bekommen
wir sind fertig für heute feierabend
brust
[Musik]
das war unsere episode vom land
vielleicht lebt ihr selbst auf dem land
oder seit gerne auf dem land dann
erzählt uns doch mal eure geschichten
hier unten in den kommentaren
wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr deutsche
vokabeln lernen wollt dann probiert doch
mal den vokabeltrainer in unserer apps
ilek aus dank unserer community also
danke euch haben wir dort viele vokabeln
mittlerweile auch schon in andere
sprachen übersetzt so könnt ihr zum
beispiel die wichtigsten 5000 deutschen
vokabeln mit spanischen russischen
portugiesischen oder chinesischen
übersetzung lernen bis bald
[Musik]